there's been this recurring meme that
keeps coming up in the debate around the
us-mexico border wall and it came up
when I interviewed Dilbert creator Scott
Adams I think it was at the beginning of
last week although time is sort of going
going by in a way that's hard to
remember I think it was the the Monday
Tuesday episodes of last week where he
keeps saying and others keep saying
Engineers should decide what happens
with the wall
engineers have the answers and they
ultimately are the ones who are going to
be able to tell us whether it does or
doesn't make sense now the context of
this is that government is still shut
down I think we're going now into week
we're in week four about to go over into
week five the government is shut down
because of Trump's temper tantrum over
wanting five billion for a piece of this
us-mexico border wall now from a
political perspective I made the point
to Scott Adams and I've made it other
times that I actually don't think
engineers should decide about the wall
engineers can tell us a lot about the
wall but no matter what they tell us
about the building of the wall and the
cost of the wall engineers don't have
the political answers about whether
national priorities should dictate that
we do or don't spend any money on a wall
as one example but okay there are people
who are insisting that so-called
engineers should tell us what should
happen with the wall it turns out that
engineers have actually looked at this
and they've determined that the wall is
a veritable disaster both in terms of
effectiveness and in terms of the cost I
actually got an email from a licensed
structural and civil engineer who has a
master's degree in structural
engineering from one of the top programs
in the country he has more than 10 years
experience in major projects he's an
adjunct professor of structural analysis
at a university so this is someone that
actually has the practical and the
theoretical experience to look at a
project like the us-mexico border wall
and he's actually been brought in as an
expert witness on matters regarding
proper wall construction into court
cases okay so this is literally an
expert on building big walls and the
results of what he and other engineers
have looked at tell us that the wall is
a disaster as proposed and I want to
restate
before we get into the details this
segment is not about the political
aspects I've already explored those
aspects in terms of is there a crisis
what is it that we should and shouldn't
be doing when it comes to dealing with
immigration this is for those who simply
say what do engineers say about the wall
first of all the proposals that the
Trump administration received are from
contractors they're not strictly
speaking from engineers contractors may
employ engineers to do part of the
analysis or of the proposal but all of
these favorable proposals about how
cheap and effective the wall is going to
be these are effectively sales documents
these are contractors that want to make
money by selling a wall to the US
government let's now put up the list of
issues that have been found by multiple
engineering analyses of these proposals
number one putting in such a wall would
reduce the ability to drain land in
flash flooding regardless of whether the
wall has so-called hole holes or is
see-through as Donald Trump has
mentioned and this will significantly
increase the risk of flooding which is
going to be a real problem in a lot of
ways including the landowners in that
area to farm land roads and so many
other problems number two the proposals
that Donald Trump and others keep
pointing to which are now a couple years
old would do not account for the
ecological impacts the wall would be an
ecological disaster partially because of
the increased risk of flooding and for
many other reasons and no environmental
site assessment has been done which any
serious engineering team would do if
they were going to build a wall like
this now the question I have in
parentheses here is does anybody who
wants the wall built care about the
environmental impact of this wall it's
not totally clear problem number three
with the wall this is not my list of
problems it's the engineers list of
problems number three the prototypes
that have been proposed and and even
built for you know 20 feet of width or
whatever it was they would be nearly
impossible to build at scale or wouldn't
actually do the job so there's a few
examples about this from a GAO report
number one the prototypes are
substantially or extensively flawed
their cost is drastically underestimated
all of the concrete prototypes failed to
rank satisfactory in terms of the five
ways they're measured scaling breaching
constructibility engineering design and
aesthetics and there's many details
about each particular prototype but
every single one of them fell short of a
satisfactory ranking by the GAO report
total disaster number four the cost
estimates that have been given are
completely unreasonable the reasons that
the cost estimates from these proposals
are wrong include number one that we're
still citing a two year old estimate
even though materials costs are way way
up partially because of Donald Trump's
tariffs but also because of inflation
and other reasons number two the pricing
that the proposals Trump points to
include are based on building the wall
not on building the wall in the actual
locations where Donald Trump wants it
and what I mean by that is that the
proposals don't account for the
difficult terrain that exists in many
parts of the us-mexico border
the huge additional cost that would be
required to get materials and to house
people in a lot of these locations so
the costs are outrageously
underestimated none of it accounts for
modifications that would need to be done
to prevent flooding and environmental
hazards which as I mentioned in items 1
and 2 haven't even been looked at so
realistically Trump talks about 5
billion now the entire project could be
15 20 billion by some estimates actual
engineering analyses suggest that we
could be looking at 50 billion dollars
here the bottom line assessment again
from a court-approved wall expert is
that this is a wall that is not going to
be built in trumps lifetime never mind
during Trump's presidency and number 5
problem with the wall is that defeat
methods already exist or soon will so we
talk about how effective will the wall
be will the wall obviously keep people
out if you put the wall across the
entire border no one's going to be able
to get in well
anybody with basic construction
knowledge could go out and buy a 32-foot
extension ladder put a cheap custom
saddle on it to get over the top of the
wall without being spiked or hurt by
what's going to be on top and
furthermore within 10 years there will
be drones that can lift someone 40 feet
off the ground and put them down on the
other side and you'd better believe that
coyotes smugglers of undocumented
immigrants will get them with the
current monitoring technology and any of
the walls that have been proposed so far
we cannot stop them if they have that so
the bottom line is that for everybody
who keeps insisting the engineers know
what's going on let the engineers decide
the actual wall experts not contractors
who are looking to score huge government
contracts for a project that's going to
go on indefinitely without completion
and make them a ton of money actual wall
experts and engineers who have looked at
this agree that the plan is a joke now
Pat we're linking to the reports that
I've sourced for this story in the
description for the YouTube video for
this segment do you think anyone who's
committed to the wall is going to have
their mind ship minds changed by any of
those reports not if they're totally
committed but if they're on the fence if
you will maybe they will have their mind
changed I think this is the best way to
argue against the wall focus on the
logistics focus on the efficacy the
arguments about morality and cost those
are interesting but I don't know how
persuasive they are necessarily talking
about how we're gonna build this thing
across the Rio Grande how we're gonna
protect the tributaries if they're if
we're using steel slats can't they just
be cut through that's the kind of stuff
I like to focus on when talking about
the wall there's another element to this
also which I alluded to but I want to
mention again the amount of time it
would take to build any significant
portion of this wall is longer than the
amount of time Donald Trump is going to
remain president of the United States
and this is why there's the political
reality and there's the engineering
reality and there's the expense reality
it would be nice if more of the people
maintaining the government shutdown that
we have now going on who knows how long
and affecting 800,000 federal
workers and millions of contractors it
would be nice if some of the people who
are blindly in favor of the wall because
of what it represents rather than what
it actually do what would do if some of
these people would realize hold on a
second
even if Trump gets the five billion it
is going to be years before we see any
significant progress on this wall and
the next president could easily just say
it's over we're not doing any more if
they realize that maybe they actually
would come to the table and say okay you
know what let's put the wall aside for a
moment we can all agree about drones and
cameras and motion sensors and other
types of technology let's combine that
with punishing the corporations that are
actually taking advantage of the
undocumented immigrants let's work on
that and deal with a huge portion of the
problem and then let's focus on the
two-thirds of the undocumented
immigrants who are here because of
overstayed visas not because they
physically crossed the us-mexico border
we could make so much more progress at a
far lower cost but there's no big
political win there Donald Trump and
many of his acolytes and sycophants have
decided that it's the idea of the wall
that represents victory even if the wall
itself is a pipe dream that even if we
started working on tomorrow with five
billion is simply not going to be
completed during Donald Trump's
presidency and maybe not even his
lifetime according to the structural
engineer that I've been speaking with
send me your thoughts send me your
thoughts about the reports send me your
thoughts about what it might take to
actually change the minds of some of
these the wall over all else people I'm
on Twitter at the Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show we'll take
a quick break and be back after this
with much more of today's news okay
let's talk about Fox News propaganda
sean hannity we've been covering Hannity
on this program for a very long time and
the sort of tone and tenor of his
program has shifted over the last
several years particularly under the
Trump regime and lately Hannity has been
falling all over himself to do a couple
of different things on his Fox News
program one of Hannity's priorities has
been he's trump's buddy and a priority
has been defend
Trump
all costs we know that Hannity and Trump
sometimes will talk on the phone right
before Trump goes to bed he wants to
defend Trump at all costs that's
Priority One for Hannity priority two
for Hannity on the Hannity program on
fox news has been he wants to take
himself out of harm's way of the Muller
probe if possible because given
Hannity's connections not only to Trump
but also to Trump's now convicted
personal lawyer Michael Cohen hannity
has a really big incentive to frame the
entire molar probe as nothing but a
political witch-hunt just like Donald
Trump has been doing and then number
three Hannity has an incentive to oppose
any policy that's bad for him personally
so an example of this would be a newly
inaugurated congresswoman Alexandra
Ocasio courts has floated the idea of a
70% top marginal tax rate for the top
earning Americans Hannity makes between
25 and 35 million dollars per year he
would no doubt be hit very hard by such
attacks
so what Hannity has now done and it's
stunning even for Fox News that this is
being allowed he has gone full deep
state conspiracy theorists on his show I
have a segment from his show this week
and I'm gonna play a few clips of it for
you in a moment
and it's very very disturbing
particularly don't let any little kids
see this because it's really the stuff
of nightmares now if you're uninitiated
in the deep state deep state is a
version of shadow government conspiracy
theories I recently told you in a story
last week about Eric Trump more or less
the idea of deep state and shadow
government conspiracies is okay there's
the official government as we know it
you've got a president you've got the
Senate and the House of Representatives
the Supreme Court the FBI these are all
publicly known law enforcement and
elected officials that's the official
government that we know of the
conspiracy goes that they don't actually
wield the power okay they are merely
puppets and the real power is held by
private corporations people
organizations that are sometimes shadowy
so if you've heard of the Bilderberg
Group
conspiracy theories trilateral
commission conspiracy theories the Jews
are actually in control conspiracy
theories
the Freemasons or the Vatican those are
all different flavors of shadow
government conspiracies deep state is
just one of those okay and of course
there's always like this tiny grain of
something that could be considered true
in all of these that's how they grasp
people and pull them in so in this case
it's that yeah
elites and corporations have
disproportionate power in our society
they have disproportionate lobbying
power they have disproportionate
economic power and power over labor
compared to Joe Schmo Jane Doe
middle-class guy and gal so that's how
people often will initially get sucked
in then they go down the rabbit hole
into all sorts of belligerent ideas that
brings us back to Sean Hannity Hannity
is now combining the molar probe the FBI
investigation into Trump being a Russian
asset which we learned about over the
weekend and a whole bunch of other stuff
into this neat and tidy deep state
conspiracy let's take a look at the
beginning of his monologue from a
program earlier this week time for a
bombshell Hannity watch on the deep
state tonight this takes a lot of
explaining we're gonna make it very
understandable break it down for you
it's the abuse of power corruption
remember we've been telling you all
about this it is tonight far worse than
we have ever known up until this point
yeah it's hard to explain because it's
all lies I like how he says it says this
is this is difficult to explain yeah
because it's not real Sean and I'm not
going to subject you to the entire 14
minute thing it's out there if you want
it but check out some of these key
moments we now know top people within
the FBI filled with hatred and frankly
anti-trump rage have put us all IDE all
values and their blatant political bias
we're seeking redemption for the firing
of James Comey they actually plotted to
destroy your duly elected president and
this goes way beyond what we already
knew up until this point so this is all
total hyperbole
what actually happened is the FBI was
distraught over the facts and they
decided to investigate Trump which is
exactly what they should do they should
just go where the evidence points them
we'll skip ahead a little bit here at
which point we get to the following
admission of corruption and abuse of
power by people that are unchecked a
bureaucracy unto itself unlimited powers
no accountability is any of this good
for America this is just the best
unchecked power and people a bureaucracy
with unlimited power and no
accountability Trump hired most of these
people or chose for them to stay in
their positions and they're mostly
Republicans and the check on their power
is that Trump aspire to force the bunch
of them to resign this is exactly the
stuff that trumpets and the fox fiends
as I call them they are mesmerized by
this stuff they see the story and they
come away outraged without realizing
that there's absolutely no substance
here and then Hannity goes deep state in
full these deep state officials that we
have been done covering now for nearly
two years did they do anything other
these top officials then hate the
president and are you really surprised
remember these are the same bureaucrats
they openly ruined it for Hillary
Clinton to win the election Peter struck
texting that Hillary Clinton should win
a hundred million to zero there's this
hilarious thing where the deep state
people are sort of getting mixed up
which is that the deep state is supposed
to be a shadow government but Hannity is
calling people like the FBI director
deep State the FBI director isn't part
of the shadow government they're part of
the real government so how is it that
the shadow government is the real
government but it's also the deep state
its incoherent and Hannity goes on and
on and on and it's all lies he says the
Trump Russia dossier was bogus every
week more of that dossier is
corroborated he accuses everyone of
being part of the conspiracy which is
hilarious except for the fact that his
audience buys it and eventually Hannity
uses this opening monologue to
transition into the so-called border
crisis blaming the shutdown on Democrats
which is exactly what we would expect
for him to do and when I see Trump head
lines like the FBI plotted to take down
Trump what I'm hearing is Hannity is
very worried that he's personally
wrapped up in this in some way and we
might soon find out exactly how think
back to how panicked Hannity was when we
learned that Michael Cohen's apartment
and office had been raided by the FBI
last thought on this law-and-order these
people claimed to be all about law and
order is it law and order to
propagandize to turn the public against
American law enforcement I thought that
the right was against turning the public
against law enforcement what we do know
is that it doesn't seem to work out
super well to go to war with the FBI and
we'll see how it works out for Sean
Hannity I'm not expecting any
repercussions though from Fox News
judging from Hannity's ratings he's sort
of failing Fox News Rachel Maddow is now
regularly outdoing sean hannity in the
most important demographic on that 9:00
p.m. Eastern Time Eastern time slot but
regardless it seems as though Fox
executives must be sleeping or complicit
in this nonsense because it is stunning
that this is even allowed to go on it's
an interesting time to be alive and I
know for sure I will continue not
watching any Fox News other than these
summaries I get in my email which lead
to stories like these send me your
thoughts i'm on instagram at david
pakman the show is on instagram at david
pakman show Mary Ann Cooper is joining
me next we now have two more prominent
Democratic presidential candidates after
this weekend we have congresswoman Tulsi
Gabbard of Hawaii we have Julian Castro
former Secretary of HUD under Obama and
former mayor of San Antonio Texas
there are many identity games to be
played here Tulsi Gabbard the first
Hindu member of Congress would be the
first Hindu president she's the first
American Samoan member of Congress would
be the first Samoan President Julian
Castro could be the first Hispanic
president Wow okay I'm not going to be
playing any of those games in the
Democratic primary all right I'll talk
about identity politics actually on the
Friday show and audience questions but
I'm not going to be playing those games
I'm not saying identity is not relevant
but I am going to focus on policy at
this stage of the game I've said before
playing identity games or electability
games about who will trump more
successfully be able to make fun of half
the country doesn't vote okay any good
candidate can win on turnout alone and
during the primary I'm gonna focus on
which candidates politics aligned with
mine period and we're going to start
today I'm not going to list a huge
laundry list of issues on which war
Elizabeth Warren Julian Castro and Tulsi
Gabbard agree that doesn't make sense
we're gonna focus on the differences and
unfortunately with Julian Castro we're
still missing some of that key
information since he may not have
commented on all of these issues
publicly but what I can tell you is that
based on everything I knew before this
announcement about Tulsi Gabbard and
Julian Castro but more importantly after
doing deep dives into her politics over
the weekend which is much more on record
and Julian Castro what I can tell you
with certitude today's I will not be
supporting Tulsi Gabbard / Elizabeth
Warren okay from my knowledge of Julian
Castro's politics I would be sort of
choosing between Warren and Castro with
my initial impression being that Castro
is more of a sort of centrist corporate
type dem or as Elizabeth Warren at least
in rhetoric is more of a progressive
Democrat but we're going to get into
that in more detail as we learn more
about Julian Castro's full platform as
far as Tulsi Gabbard and again I'm not
playing the identity games or
electability games I'm simply telling
you the policies of Tulsi Gabbard that
push me away and towards Elizabeth
Warren or maybe Julian Castro that's
what I'm going to get into today and for
people saying well why aren't you
talking about Richard oh Jetta I
interviewed Richard Oh Jetta who's a
West Virginia state Rep a couple of
weeks ago I am NOT going to be
supporting Richard Oh Jetta I did not
feel that he had a good understanding of
a lot of economic and tax policy during
our interview he started talking about
other Democrats as not being real
Democrats and I pointed out he voted for
Trump in 2016 I don't think that's a
good
attack he's not my guy okay so at this
point I'm just going to talk about Tulsi
gabbard's position here number one Tulsi
gabbard's a policy platform on business
regulation is reduce regulations on
corporations I don't subscribe to the
idea that a primary pillar of improving
our society will come from reducing
regulations on business period okay
Elizabeth Warren wants to establish more
oversight on corporations that's a
perspective that is in line with my view
so that is an area I disagree with Tulsi
Gabbard on the foreign policy of Tulsi
Gabbard is extraordinarily concerning to
me she has appeared on Fox News to
praise Vladimir Putin and criticized
Barack Obama's foreign policy towards
Putin which was a sort of initial red
flag Tulsi Gabbard has praised Russian
intervention in Syria I'm against that
okay an example tweet from Tulsi Gabbard
about that issue says quote al Qaeda
attacked us on 9/11 and must be defeated
Obama won't bomb them in Syria Putin did
hashtag never forget 9/11 I do not
support intervention in Syria to help
Bashar al-assad retain power period
that's not my politics Gabbard voted
against condemning the human rights
abuses and war crimes of Bashar
al-assad's regime that's not anything
that I identify as the left I can get
behind that's the sort of Leninist left
that I've sometimes referred to
Elizabeth Warren's position on that
issue on the other hand is President
Obama was right to seek congressional
approval she would prefer us not be
involved in Syria she wants troops out
but she understands that The Situation's
complex involving the Kurds and many
other factions and it's important to
know why Trump made the decision to pull
troops from Syria when he made it I
agree with that that's basically my
position I don't agree with Tulsi
gabbard's position on that issue on gay
marriage you might say well hold on
everybody all these candidates are for
gay marriage that's true Tulsi Gabbard
is currently for a gay marriage like all
the other candidates so far but she used
to be an tag
she actually called activists for gay
marriage quote homosexual extremists
multiple times and even though they've
all arrived at what are very similar
positions today I would still find
relevant that she at any point although
good for her that she changed her mind
used this language about people who said
hey we should be able to get married as
well
tulsi gabbard also tweeted once when we
talk about conspiracies type type stuff
that Turkey is a supporter of Isis that
is simply not true and lastly her
political action committee Tulsi PAC
funds a lot of sort of centrist and more
right-wing Democrats over progressive
Democrats so the way that money is
allocated in that way is not in line
with my politics so what I'm saying Pat
is she's she's too far right for me okay
I don't support Assad defenders I don't
support people who dabble in unfounded
conspiracies so for right now I'm with
Elizabeth Warren I'm gonna spend some
more time today researching Julian
Castro and we're going to go from there
and you know as well as I do Pat I'm
gonna take heat for this I'm going to
take heat for this because Tulsi Gabbard
is popular in certain circles of the
left but it's it's not it's not my
politics what I will say for now is it's
great that the three major presidential
candidates Elizabeth Warren Tulsi
Gabbard and Julian Castro they all
support Medicare for all and they're of
course the first three to announce their
candidacy so it's it's making the the
standard in the Democratic Party one
that you have to support Medicare for
all to be taken seriously we'll see if
the other candidates follow suit like if
the establishment types bite in even
Hillary Clinton if they decide to run
we'll see if they adopt that position
too that's very good and then from there
we can decide who is the most
progressive who is the best candidate
but having that as a starting point
that's major absolutely totally agree
and we've been hoping actually that
Medicare for all not a litmus test but
just how can you support the system we
have or small tweaks to it
given its major failures that doesn't
sound very progressive last thing I want
to mention on this I'm not going to be
influenced by Tulsi Gabbard having
endorsed Bernie
in 2016 okay last night when I was
researching i eated on my twitter
account at des Pakman what do you see as
the primary distinguishing factors
between Warren Castro and Gabbard and a
bunch of people told me Warren did
endorsed Hillary did not endorse Bernie
Sanders played coy waited around and
then endorsed Hillary a Castro just
wasn't a big player in 2016 and tulsi
gabbard endorsed Bernie Sanders what
about that I'm going to evaluate tulsi
gabbard based on her positions okay I'm
not going to be swayed by the fact that
in 2016
she liked Bernie Sanders the most that's
not really a factor for me at this point
in time because she now is running she
has her own positions up notice I want
to go back to this I've said nothing
about electability I've said nothing
about identity stuff there are major
differences here in these candidates in
terms of who will actually be a player
in the 2020 Democratic primary just from
the three people I talked about today
I don't think all three of them are
going to be major players in the primary
but I'm not dealing with that right now
I'm focusing on policy and what's
knowable from public statements and that
is the way I am going to handle this
primary and I know that there are people
who are going to email me and say David
you should be considering things like
who can go toe-to-toe with Trump's
insult style who is actually going to
appeal to the amorphous Midwestern
Democrats or the Southern Blue Dog
Democrat or turnout is 50% okay the
right candidate can defeat Donald Trump
and I'm going to focus on policy send me
your thoughts make sure you're following
the show on instagram at david pakman
show make sure you're following me at
David Pakman on Instagram we'll be
taking questions there about the 20/20
slate of candidates let's now talk about
the shutdown the weekend has gone by it
has come and gone the shutdown now
continues into I guess we're now into
week four because it's it's been more
than three weeks not yet for I think so
I believe that we're in week four of the
shutdown at this point
and it's kind of becoming the biggest
joke running and I'm going to speak a
more this week to a couple of friends
who work under the Department of
Homeland Security I texted with them
over the weekend none of them are
getting paid there's this unclear sort
of big picture of all of the people
under DHS that are not getting paid who
may support the shutdown because they
want the wall but it's not clear that
all of them do and a lot of them aren't
getting paid because Trump has shut down
the government in order to get for the
the money for the wall which they might
support I mean it's a mess at this point
and Republicans actually had the
opportunity to get Donald Trump to end
the shutdown Republicans came up with a
bill to end the shutdown they negotiated
it with other Republicans and Donald
Trump has now rejected him there's been
this growing list of Republicans and I
told you last week some Republicans are
starting to realize that the shutdown is
starting to have political implications
for them there are also real world
implications on a ton of people in this
country who aren't getting paid part of
Miami Airport has now been shut down and
I've pointed out that the airport shut
down stuff could become a real crippling
factor for industry there are
Republicans who say it's time to get
beyond this they are saying we're
willing to end it without funding for
the wall at least initially of course
that was the reason Trump shut down the
government so over the weekend Senate
Republicans who want to end the shutdown
were able to negotiate with other
Republicans a bill that would do exactly
that and what they came up with was well
we'll fund some departments that are
currently shut down we'll fund some
border security but we're not going to
specifically fund the wall will let
committees later sort out whether or how
we're going to fund the wall so a block
of Republicans negotiated this with
other Republicans okay
Republicans who want to reopen
government without the wall against the
Republicans who say no we absolutely
need the wall to reopen government they
agreed okay Republicans agreed with
Republicans to do this and then Donald
Trump rejected it Mike Pence and chief
of staff Mick Mulvaney brought it to
Trump and Trump immediately shot it down
and so the question I'm going back to is
the one
we asked last week which is this Trump
feel like he's winning here and it
appears that he does completely whacked
out Senator Lindsey Graham says quote I
think we're stuck I just don't see a
path forward I don't see a way forward
and Trump reportedly told Graham and
some other senators that he believes he
is actually winning on this it's also
hilarious but incredibly depressing that
Mitch McConnell is number one managing
to stay almost completely out of the
news how I don't know because he's one
of the major players in keeping
government shutdown but McConnell is
rejecting deals that other Democrats
have put forward which are identical to
deals that Republicans have previously
agreed to and they aren't even taking
seriously the proposals of some of the
more moderate Republicans beyond this
one which was again brought to Trump and
Trump immediately rejected it so what
you've got to understand here Pat is
that House Democrats are passing
Republican bills to reopen government
Mitch McConnell won't even put them up
for the Senate to vote on and we're
supposed to believe that everybody's
equally to blame for this fiasco yeah
that sounds like Trump is losing friends
in his own party and he's really not in
a position to do that not with the
Democrats taking over power in the house
and starting over starting up a bunch of
new investigations not with the Muller
report coming out maybe in the next you
know weeks or months he really has to
hold steady that Republican base make
sure that he's getting along with
Republican senators because they could
end up turning on him they could take a
look at what's going on with a shutdown
here and decide that it would be a lot
easier to work with Mike Pence instead
and announce the guy I wonder I mean
okay so I think back when we when I
think about would Trump be punished by
voters if he allowed government to be
reopened without funding for the wall I
think back to this guy that called in I
don't remember his name but just that
outrageous Trump supporter who called in
who talked all about how the wall the
wall the wall he supports Trump because
of the wall and I said to him okay what
could Trump do that would make it so
that you don't vote for Trump in 2020
and this guy said well he's got to build
he's got to build the wall and so
I said all right so if Trump doesn't
build the wall are you saying you will
not vote for him in 2020 and the guy
immediately backed off and basically
said well actually I'm not really sure
about that if he tried to build it but
Democrats prevented him from building it
then maybe I would still vote for him
and that's why I actually think Pat that
he's not going to be punished even
though it's embarrassing that he said
Mexico would pay for it which they never
would I think even if he allows the
government to reopen without funding for
the wall most of his followers aren't
gonna go and vote for Elizabeth Warren
right or Tulsi Gabbard I just don't
think they'll punish him I think the
best way out politically for everyone in
this scenario is for Trump to cave to
pass the budget without the funding for
the wall and then to declare his
national emergency say he's going to use
the military to build the wall then the
courts strike it down because in that
scenario he can just point to these
liberal activists judges and blamed them
for the reason why the wall wasn't able
to be built and and yet he's still able
to go to in front of his supporters and
say that I did the best I could I tried
to institute a travel ban that got shut
down by the courts I tried to build a
wall that got shut down by the courts
I'm only one person here I can only do
so much that's also the best because it
will have been struck down according to
him by the liberal activist judges
increasingly appointed by him right I
mean like with every passing month Trump
is responsible for more and more of the
judges that are actually on the courts
politically you may be right I actually
thought of another idea just playing on
Trump's a lack of reading what if
someone just goes to Trump and says mr.
president we got the money for the wall
we got it in the bill but we need you to
sign it right now and there's no money
for the wall in the bill Trump doesn't
read he's not going to read the bill and
even if he does read it he probably
doesn't understand the way that those
bills are written if Trump puts his
signature on it before a staffer gets a
chance to read it government gets
reopened Trump will go and say he got
money for the wall it obviously won't be
built because there was no money for the
wall in the bill and eventually Trump
will realize that and it'll be a big
loss that may actually be the best path
but of course Republicans aren't going
to do that to them or at least I can't
imagine that they're going to how long
will this go on when do you think it
will end do you think Trump will get his
five billion for part of the wall which
of course would only be a fraction of
the wall send me your thoughts today's
new member of the day is Michael honey
Chuck before I get into this
very very big story that is an
unfortunate story but an important one I
want to thank Michael for being a member
were mostly funded by members some
members have been with us for a really
long time including Ron Lindsey who's
going on five years of david pakman show
membership doesn't need you don't need
to spend 200 bucks or 150 or a hundred
to move the needle just getting a $6 a
month membership is awesome and if that
sounds high use the coupon code this is
2020 it'll save you 40% bringing down
that monthly membership to just over $3
a month if you value what we do if
you've been here for a while
it'll feel good trust me it'll feel good
to be supporting us WW join pakman.com
Michael honey Chuck Ron Lindsay thanks
to both of you okay I've been telling
you about the serious problems of the
women's March at this point for years
and when I do the story today that I'm
doing this is not an i-told-you-so story
okay this is a story about it getting
beyond even plausible deniability that
the leadership of the women's March must
go that the leadership of the women's
March does not represent the best of
progressivism and it is simply not a
movement that I as a principled
progressive can get behind I'll remind
you back when the women's March first
formed after Donald Trump's election I
praised many of the goals but after
going to one of the events in the Boston
area I questioned the execution I
questioned the identity politics focus
of the March that I personally attended
I wasn't sure what it was going to be
able to achieve based on the way that it
was structured and focused and over time
we learned about the horrible
anti-semitic and homophobic ties of some
of the leaders this includes Linda
Sarsour Tameka Mallory Bob bland
and we more recently heard that the
co-founder of the March Theresa shook
actually said this has to end these
leaders need to step down and we need
other people and she cited the
connections to known Nation of Islam
anti-semite Louis Farrakhan one of the
most toxic players in politics for the
last many decades in the United States
the praise by Linda Sarsour of the
radical group Muslim Brotherhood is
extraordinarily disturbing and something
that does not fit with progressive
values in any way and Teresa shook
called that out and I told you about
that and I praised her for demanding new
leadership most recently and we didn't
even get a chance to cover this because
it was over our break I believe a
women's March was actually cancelled now
some reports say it was canceled because
it was going to be all white people that
were planning to go and that didn't look
too good other reports are that it was
merely logistical reasons why the March
was canceled this now gets us to
yesterday okay what I have for you today
is video of two of the women's March
leaders Tameka Mallory and Bob bland and
by the way Bob bland it sounds like a 60
year old balding accountant but it's not
Bob bland is actually is a woman it's a
pseudonym for a woman whose legal name
is Mary Lynn of Folger folder I believe
it's pronounced okay they appeared on
the view they were asked very specific
questions about their associations to
Louis Farrakhan to these homophobic and
anti-semitic individuals and movements
including questions from John McCain's
daughter Megan McCain and this has only
furthered my conviction that this is a
toxic group of people that the left
should not have anything to do with
let's get into clip number one there has
been some controversy surrounding the
women's March organization and and
Tameka you came under some fire for your
relationship with Louis Farrakhan and
the Nation of Islam
now he's known for being anti-semitic
for being homophobic but you do attend
his of
and you posted I believe a photo
together calling him the goat which
means the greatest of all time and you
are running an organization that says it
fights biggest bigotry do you understand
why your association with him is quite
problematic okay so that's the question
the the right answer here is I do
understand why it's problematic even
though I've identified some things that
Louis Farrakhan has done that I think
are good it is not okay to associate
with him we are a movement that believes
in ABCD he clearly does not and
therefore we need to have allies who
share all of our values or at least you
know all of our values maybe it may be a
little bit much never going to find
anyone who agrees on everything but who
at least don't hold views so
antithetical to what our movement claims
to promote something like that would
have been the right answer you were
praising and associating with people who
espouse the opposite of the values you
claim to espouse in the March the answer
she gives is completely off the rails I
think it's important to put the my
attendance my presence at saviours day
which is the highest holy day for the
Nation of Islam in proper context you
know as a leader as a black leader in a
country that is still dealing with some
very serious unresolved issues as it
relates to the black experience in this
country I go into a lot of difficulties
I wrote a piece immediately following
the beginning of this controversy
talking about wherever my people are
that's where I must also be so I also go
into prisons where there are people who
have been convicted of heinous acts and
I am trying to help people to move from
wherever they are today and build that
unity to bring them to a place where we
live in a more fair and equitable
society and I think that that work is
not easy for everyone to understand but
it's certainly work that I'm committed
to and everywhere that I go is difficult
the women's March was very difficult
this is such a laughable answer that
it's hard to know where to start she
does number one she does a pivot to
talking about how she goes to a lot of
difficult places to do activism and that
people are just gonna have to understand
that that's that's something she does
for the greater good she says I also go
to prisons to help out and people there
have done some bad things as well that's
a complete red herring that's a death a
joke that's not an argument and then she
also says we'll hold on a second I went
to an event of the Nation of Islam so
basically what she's saying is you have
to ignore everything that the Nation of
Islam and Farrakhan stand for because
she just went to an event because some
of her people were there this is like
saying listen Christmas is an important
day for Christians so you have to ignore
what the Westboro Baptist Church stands
for God hates [ __ ] and all that stuff I
was there because Christmas is important
and they're a Christian Church and I'm a
Christian period and anything else would
be inappropriate to bring up as a
criticism total joke and she should be
embarrassed then and it's about to get
much better in comes Meghan McCain and
you'll notice that after Meghan McCain
makes a number of proven allegations
here the other host asked Tamika Mallory
whether those are accurate allegations
which is a great thing like let's just
get an answer here do you accept that
this is what's been said do you denounce
what's been said and Tamika Mallory just
very pompously points to Bob bland and
says you answer and avoids having to
give a yes or no on that you just
interject fairly quickly I would never
be comfortable supporting someone who
called
I'm not anti-semite and I'm an anti
termite it's the Wicked Jews the false
Jews that are promoting lesbianism
homosexuality actually spoke with the
journalist from tablet magazine who
released an investigation reports on
your organization and in part they
alleged that there is a lot of
anti-semitism surrounding this March
specifically the report alleged that you
Tamika and co-founder Carmen Perez
asserted that quote Jewish people had a
history of exploiting black people and
were proven to be leaders of the
American slave trade now a lot of people
buy a lot of people I include me in this
think that you're using your
organization as anti-semitism masked and
activism and that you're using identity
politics to shield yourself from
critiques we're talking about all women
being invited to that March I'm pro-life
we were not invited
we were not allowed at that March right
there I'm a conservative woman I also
represent you're talking about women we
talk about all women
including Jewish women as well and
conservative well first of all those
allegations are not true that is not how
that meeting happened and the women's
March that the German equity was lying
the the people that the journalists
spoke to did not tell the truth just
completely off the rails Tameka Mallory
just refusing to answer Bob Linn saying
the information about that meeting is
untrue Megan McCain listed a whole
litany of statements and claims and the
responses that meeting didn't go that
way as if the issue here is one meeting
and then lastly and this is just
difficult to watch I mean it really is
because it's so embarrassing Tameka
Mallory plays coy with whether she
denounces this stuff or not and good for
them for going back and trying to get a
straight answer about this I don't speak
for Jewish people but I think I'm just
confused
if these remarks are I mean it goes on
death to Israel over and over again we
did not make those you can't but you're
associating with a man what how likely
what I will say to you is that I don't
agree with many of Minister Farrakhan
statement specifically about Jewish
people as I said I don't agree with many
of Minister Farrakhan statement I
condemn them eight I don't agree with
these statements at the end of the day
welcome it no no no to be very clear
it's not my language it's not the way
that I speak this is this playing coy
that Richard Spencer did with me on this
show and I'll play a clip for you in a
moment do you condemn the language well
there are many ideas he has that are not
my ideas okay well do you condemn the
statements about Jewish people he says
many things I don't agree with what's so
difficult about just saying hey you know
what I do condemn it I do condemn a
period and this is the same tactic that
white nationalists Richard Spencer tried
playing with me when I interviewed him a
couple years ago check it out I mean
it's almost the exact same game I heard
that you'd will you denounced Adolf
Hitler I heard you don't denounce Adolf
Hitler when asked about that Adolf
National Socialism was it was a
was a disaster the 20th century was a
pretty much a disaster yeah but do you
denounce the action of Adolf Hitler I'm
not gonna get I'm not gonna get I'm not
gonna play this game I can't throw out
historical figures and I denounce them I
mean do you denounce Stalin do you
denounce Pol Pot I mean look yeah the
the National Socialist Germany it's
rings a bell right the movement was bad
they made mistakes but do you denounce
Farrakhan in a statements do you
denounce Hitler Tameka Mallory well they
said some things that are that are not
things I would say Spencer well the
movement was a disaster for national
socialism it's not that difficult to
denounce this stuff give me a break and
the bottom line here is this is not
about litmus tests or about dividing the
left and I told you yesterday and you
you pointed this out as well Pat when we
look at tulsi gabbard we don't
necessarily see progressivism in her
foreign policy but that doesn't mean
it's a bad thing that it's another
candidate who supports single-payer
health care for example or even some of
her economic views may not be what we
agree with but maybe others are when I
look at the women's March leadership I
simply don't see individuals that I can
support and be proud of in terms of a
progressive movement period and
ultimately Pat people have to decide for
themselves what they're comfortable with
I'm not comfortable with this
yeah the women's March was largely
successful especially the first one half
a million to a million people turned out
in Washington DC and then millions more
across the country but I think it's
damaged beyond repair at this point even
if they do change around the leadership
you're not gonna get beyond that I think
it's time to wrap it up and call it a
day I tend to agree and sadly because
the activism that has been catalyzed by
the current president and his
administration is something we don't
want to squander but I think that it is
beyond repair at this point send me your
thoughts i'm on instagram at david
pakman the show is on instagram at david
pakman show I'll be taking questions
there this week about this and any other
topics
Kentucky Senator and ophthalmologist
Rand Paul is known as one of the more
kind of strictly libertarian members of
the US Senate and one of his I call it
one of his greatest hits in terms of
just saying whacky things was when he
said that single-payer health
CAIR is effectively slavery that it
makes dr. slaves that it makes nurses
slaves everybody's a slave when you have
single-payer health care and we've now
learned he's going to be going to health
care slavery headquarters Canada for a
hernia operation you can't write this
stuff so I want to take this piece by
piece with you let me set it up first
here's Rand Paul with his now infamous
claim that single-payer health care is a
form of slavery thank you very much with
regard to the idea of whether or not you
have a right to a healthcare you have to
realize what that implies it's not an
abstraction I'm a physician that means
you have a right to come to my house and
can script me means you believe in
slavery it means that you're going to
enslave not only me but the janitor at
my hospital the person who cleans my
office the assistants who work in my
office the nurses if you have a right to
their services basically once you imply
a belief in a right to someone services
you have a right to plumbing so there it
is everyone is a slave in a single-payer
health care system according to Rand
Paul if you have single-payer health
care everybody involved in the system is
condemned to a lifetime of slavery and
I'm assuming that when he says that when
he makes that critique he believes
slavery is bad so that he wouldn't want
to be participating in such a sick
system except that Senator Rand Paul is
now opting to go to Canada for hernia
surgery remember that incident that took
place where Rand Paul was I guess raking
leaves on his front lawn and a neighbor
who I believe was an anesthesiologist
tackled him and Rand Paul ended up with
six broken ribs and a bruised lung and
apparently this hernia resulted from the
incident as well or from the recovery
from the incident so we have this market
system which I guess he believes is
great in the United States socialized
medicine is bad Canadians are being put
on horrible waiting lists for
non-emergency procedures but it turns
out that shul D sore shoulders I'm not
exactly sure how it's pronounced hernia
Hospital in Ontario is a really good
place to have hernia repair done and
that's where Rand Paul is going to go
now I'm gonna anticipate already what
the defenders of
Rand Paul are going to say they will
write in and say David hold on I am
opposed to the socialized medicine
system like Rand Paul but this
particular hospital that Rand Paul is
going to is a private hospital not a
public hospital that is true by the
letter but most of the money of this
clinic comes from the government they
accept the socialized health care plan
they're doing just fine no slaves no
problems one of the best places in the
world to have hernia repair done and
it's a perfectly reasonable model you
don't need to have the government be the
healthcare provider and the employer of
the doctors and the employer of the
nurses you still can have private
hospitals but you have one pair which is
the government which provides a system
of non-profit health insurance period
just because the provider is private as
is the case here
understand that it's mostly a publicly
funded provider and that's a model
that's very popular in the single-payer
world and what we have in the end is
Rand Paul choosing because of the
quality of care at a mostly publicly
funded health clinic in health care
slavery a hub Canada he is taking his
tax payer salary out of the United
States and to a different country and I
was thinking pat on the one hand there's
this kind of hypocrisy or double
standard in another sense this is sort
of libertarianism as intended by them
he's rich and powerful so he can go to
Canada and get better care other people
can't even afford the flight to Canada
never mind paying for the care as a non
citizen so they end up with the care
that happens to be available to them
with their terrible health insurance in
the part of the country where they
happen to live it's both an incredible
double standard but a version of
libertarianism that a lot of people like
Rand Paul actually support I really just
can't get over how dumb the argument is
that if you are for single-payer health
care you're for slavery like doctors are
compensated a good deal of money they
make six-figure salaries they don't have
to be in that position if they don't
want to they're free to go you can't say
the same thing about slaves and
if you're gonna make this slavery
argument when it comes to the universal
health care you have to make it when it
comes to any public official like Rand
Paul as a politician he's a slave to
apparently we will see what other follow
up there is from Rand Paul here and
it'll probably just kind of fade away
like many of these stories do
it's just our elected officials being
hypocritical that that sadly is not
actually news